Speaker 1: It may or may not surprise you that
the Texas sheriff who is now conducting a criminal
investigation into the Ron DeSantis Martha's
Vineyard migrant stunt, which I told you about
yesterday, is now receiving death threats. Vice
has a very good article about this by Paul West,
Texas Sheriff Getting Death Threats after saying
he'd investigate the Santas for migrant plane
stunt. This is the party of law and order.
Remember the people who are issuing the
death threats? So the way it went is as follows.
Ron DeSantis had the bright idea to use Florida
taxpayer money to fly 48 migrants awaiting asylum
decisions from Texas to Martha's Vineyard, an
island off the coast of Massachusetts, with a very
small population and limited resources. We learned
after this took place that the migrants were lied
to. They were lured there with false promises of
jobs and other things. This led to questions as to
whether this was even legal, what Ron DeSantis did
or might qualify as human trafficking. We now have
lawyers who are representing the migrants who have
filed a civil suit. We will talk about that on the
bonus show. And we have this Texas sheriff named
Javier Salazar, who is criminally investigating
the Santos. I told you about that yesterday.
The Texas sheriff said, I'm going to investigate
this. It seems that these individuals were lured
and that crimes took place. And now he has
received and his office have received, quote,
numerous threats. On Tuesday, a spokesperson told
VICE News there have been numerous threats, an
influx of calls to our dispatch and administrative
offices, along with hateful emails received.
Additionally, as in any instance, when our office
receives threats, precautionary measures will be
made for safety of all personnel. These are the
people who claim to be for law and order. They
are cheering the possibly illegal stunt of luring
migrants to Martha's Vineyard. But they claim to
be for law and order. They are then threatening
the guy investigating the possible criminality
that took place. It is wild to see these law
and order people losing their minds after
calling themselves the party of law and Order for
decades and saying Comply with law enforcement,
let them do their work. Well, that's what
Sheriff Salazar is trying to do. And now they're
threatening his life and the life of officers
that work in his office. And remember, this is
only over the investigative process. There hasn't
even been any indictment or charges and that this
is related to the Trump stuff as well. The maggots
are going bonkers merely over the fact that Trump
is being investigated. Understand that the search
warrant execution is part of the investigative
phase. We haven't gotten to the indictment part.
We don't have any charges yet. And it remains
to be seen whether we will even the investigation
is enough to get them to abandon the very law and
order that they cling to almost religiously when
it's a tool or a cudgel with which they can attack
the left and attack Democrats. What's important
here to the Trump is law enforcement officers
and the Trumpist members of the military, but
for the most part, the law enforcement officers.
You should be aware that these MAGA people, as
much as they claim to support you right now,
they will turn on you in an instant if you
don't support their level of delusion. 100%.
We saw it happen with the Capitol Police. Oh, back
the blue thin blue line support law enforcement
fund. The police. All lives matter. All this
different stuff. Oh, wait. All of a sudden,
the Capitol Police were trying to stop the
Trumpists from getting into the Capitol.
Well, write them off. We mean, support
the police, but not those police.
Oh, the FBI, which is also law enforcement,
they did everything legally to execute a search
warrant at Donald Trump's home. Well, yeah, I
mean, we back the blue, but not them. I mean,
that's different. Now they're they're
becoming political. The principles don't
matter. They abandon them whenever it is not
convenient. And if you were in law enforcement,
they will abandon you if you don't live up to
their delusional expectations. We'll have all
the clips we played here on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.